This was just not one line taken out of context.
The American dream is not owning your own home.
Too many shops, too many jobs, too many people putting money in the bank.
My experience in the private sector took me one: to be head of a consulting firm that got in trouble.
America's role as leader in the world is a thing of the past.
Why don't you like ObamaCare?
What is it that's wrong with it?
The government should guarantee healthcare systems.
Tell us what kind of healthcare insurance we can have,...
...tell us what kind of treatment we can have.
Say no to fracking and no to drilling offshore.
No to drilling in Alaska.
You need to have some taxes to spread the wealth around.
For the student in school that works hard to get on the honor roll,....
...that's not really them, that's their teacher that did that and the government that paid for it.
ObamaCare is constitutional.
This president has done an extraordinary thing.
He's your guy.
If you're looking for more freedom, more opportunity, good jobs, rising incomes, a bright future for your kids.
They'd better vote for the other guy.